et on l'aura compris donc huitième round
de négociations lundi toujours aucune
avancée notamment sur les dossiers
sensibles comme la pêche et la finance
michel barnier négociateur en chef de
l'uss se lit très inquiet quant aux
anglais bien ils prennent leur temps on
aura saisi tout en voulant désormais
revenir sur certains engagements pris à
la sortie de l'union européenne la
colère monte au sein des vingt-sept d'où
cette question ce soir
faut-il mettre rapidement les anglais
sur le banc de touche de l'union
européenne pour en parler nous sommes
avec frédéric viale docteur en droit
bonsoir frédéric viale merci d'être avec
nous à ses côtés florian philippot
président du parti des patriotes bonsoir
à vous également florian philippot alors
question un peu voilà pied dans le plein
pour démarrer mais qui a le mérite
d'être clair est-ce qu'il est temps
finalement d'accélérer le mouvement est
ce qu'il ne faut pas rapidement coupé
les ponts avec les britanniques no deal
et puis tant pis frédéric viale non je
crois que la question ne devrait
véritablement ne se pose pas de cette de
cette manière là en réalité il y à des
gesticulations actuellement mais pour
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer il faut bien voir que les deux
c'est à dire aussi bien du côté de
l'union européenne que du côté du
gouvernement britannique les deux sont
des néolibéraux radicaliser qui de toute
façon veulent un accord de libre échange
alors ils sont obligés d'avoir un
discours politique pour vendre à l'euro
l'opinion que eh bien ils ont
effectivement du côté britannique fait
la rupture et du côté de l'union
européenne ils ont passé le message
comme quoi il était très difficile de
sortir de l'union européenne puisque
c'est ça que veut passer comme message
devenu rebelle mais en réalité ils sont
dans tous les deux libres échangistes et
donc finalement qu'il y ait pas d'accord
tout de suite ou qu'il y en ait un peu
plus tard ne change fondamentalement pas
au fait qu'il y aura au fond un accord
sur l'essentiel c'est à dire sur le
leurs échanges qui est le coeur même de
la nature la nature même de l'union
européenne
donc de ce point de vue là je pense
qu'il ya pas beaucoup à s'inquiéter
enfin elle pas à s'inquiéter on
s'inquiète pas du tout mais il n'y a pas
beaucoup à imaginer que il va y avoir
véritablement la nécessité de forcer les
anglais à faire quoi que ce soit ils
sont dans une logique qui est très
compréhensible finalement florian
philippot est ce qu'on n'est pas un peu
trop aimable avec un os nos chers amis
un britannique à pato ils ont voulu
quitter rapidement l'europe maintenant
il est peut-être le temps de se dire
bye-bye dans mes habitudes façon les
britanniques défendre leurs intérêts
nationale et il respecte la souveraineté
de leur peuple puisque leur peuple a
voté par référendum
et contrairement à ce qu'on avait vu en
france quand nous on a voté la dernière
fois on a eu droit de voter par
référendum sur l'europe c'est en 2005
nous on n'a pas eu droit à ce respect ça
a été bafouée par les parlementaires
trois ans plus tard que le traité de
lisbonne
donc les devants aux wings et respecter
la volonté de ne sont pas par exemple il
défend son intérêt national ça peut
entraîner des négociations un peu ap
surtout que côté l'union européenne
évidemment depuis le début tout est fait
pour qu'on mette des bâtons dans les
roues pour essayer d'unir les anglais de
leur vote pour essayer de montrer aux
autres peuples pour éviter un effet
domino évidemment pour montrer qu'on ne
peut pas quitter sans douleur
c'était valérie pécresse qui avait dit
il faut qu'il parte dans la douleur il
faut que ce soit douloureux
voilà ça c'est pas une drôle de
conception de la démocratie
moi je ne fais pas de souci pour les
britanniques ils partiront ils sont déjà
aux trois cartes partie le 31 décembre
ils seront totalement partie ils auront
la souveraineté ils pourront décider de
tout à deux choses que nous aujourd'hui
français on ne peut plus décider
démocratiquement
là c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui ils sont
sur le libre échange comme comme l'union
européenne mais la grosse différence
c'est que si demain les français aient
voté pour un gouvernement avait
l'aspiration à au protectionnisme par
exemple eh bien ils pourraient ils
auraient voté pour un gouvernement
protectionnistes puisque nous sommes
dans l'union européenne et ses traités
qui ont pour adn le libre échange on
continuerait quand même avec le
libre-échange
alors que les britanniques ils vont
choisir démocratiquement ils vont
choisir soit le libre échange
effectivement c'est plutôt leurs
traditions effectivement soit ils
pourraient choisir demain le
protectionnisme est peu ils ont le choix
non la pas et c'est vrai ça sur plein de
sujets les politiques la politique
migratoire la politique industrielle
l'éthique commerciale la politique
environnementale etc c'est toute la
différence entre un peuple libre un
peuple qui ne l'est pas alors ils ont le
droit effectivement la france en tout
cas et l'union européenne avec a le
droit d'avoir un partenaire peut être
loyal dans ces négociations c'est ce que
semble dire
gabriel atteint le porte parole du
gouvernement qui affirme aujourd'hui que
paris se prépare à tous les scénarios du
bric si tu écoutes et gabriela talent
nous avons pris connaissance comme vous
l'avez dit de ce texte diffère de
l'accord de retrait qui a été négocié et
signé
est ce que je veux dire au nom du
gouvernement français c'est que la
france attend le respect plein et entier
de l'accord de sortie qui a été signée
que nous sommes prêts à négocier de
bonne foi mais que pour cela il faut
être au mieux 2 et que nous attendra
donc
un interlocuteur à la table des
discussions de bonne foi et qui
évidemment dans ce contexte on prépare
entre tous les scénarios mais que notre
état d'esprit et de continuer la
discussion avec michel barnier mobilisés
pour cela au tour du magazine
frédéric viale je m'adresse au docteur
en droit que vous aide il ya quand même
une violation du droit international
effectivement la france n'a pas raison
n'at-elle pas raison d'attendre un
partenaire de bonne foi avec des
méthodes déloyales
non mais bien entendu mais la question
elle est qu'aujourd'hui on est dans le
cadre d'une négociation sortie avec des
échéances qui sont des échéances
politiques qui se posent au gouvernement
britannique
en réalité cette affaire là du break
site c'est un petit peu le sketch de
muriel robin si vous je sais pas si vous
vous souvenez le disque dur la coiffeuse
on coupe on coup mais on garde toute la
longueur c'est un peu ça la négociation
du bric site c'est à dire que les deux
aujourd'hui aussi bien la commission que
le gouvernement britannique vol du libre
échange
simplement ils doivent vendre à leurs
opinions d'une part pour le gouvernement
britannique qu'il a eu raison de sortir
et d'autre part pour le la commission
européenne que elle veut passer le
message aux peuples européens que
l'union européenne on ne l'aiment pas et
on ne la quitte pas voilà c'est ça le
les confrontations des deux donc en fait
on est dans une à un moment de
rodomontades politique où chacun montre
ses muscles et chacun montre ses muscles
pour essayer de dire c'est moi qui vais
obtenir le meilleur accord n'est en
réalité
sur le fond il y a très peu de
différence entre les deux c'est à dire
entre ce que joël gouvernement
britannique aujourd'hui est ce que je la
commission ce qui se passe c'est que le
gouvernement britannique saute sur
l'accord de pêche et sur l'irlande pour
dire à son opinion publique
oui moi je fais un accord de rupture
mais en réalité en dehors de ça on va il
faut trouver et je suis à peu près
certain ils vont trouver
un accord y compris en sacrifiant les
intérêts par exemple l'union européenne
va sacrifier l'intérêt des pêcheurs
français j'en suis absolument convaincu
pour trouver finalement un accord au
bord du gouffre mais c'est à chaque fois
ce genre de rodomontades je crois qu'il
n'y a rien là d'extrêmement vraiment de
d'extrêmement définitif
florian philippot vous vous partagez
cette analyse frédéric viale on imagine
que ça vous et en vos vos oreilles chez
les patriots sacrifier l'intérêt des
pêcheurs français
vous pensez que c'est ce qui va se
passer au final à moi j'ai toujours dit
aux pêcheurs français n'en voulait pas
au britannique les britanniques ils ont
voté est évident évidemment les
gouvernements le vin britannique va
défendre les pêcheurs britannique ça
faut pas s'attendre à autre chose il va
pas défendre les pêcheurs français
non il faut en vouloir au gouvernement
français qui d'abord dans sur l'ensemble
du globe parce que la france n'allait
pas que en europe c'est aussi le
deuxième espace maritime du monde sur
l'ensemble de nos espaces pensée dans le
monde ont fait très mal respecté notre
espace maritime notre espace de pêche
1 vous en parlait le fabriquer lui année
ils en savent quelque chose
et par ailleurs la france s'est mise
tout de suite dans une situation depuis
le début de ce break site dans une
situation de blocage de tension au lieu
de négocier sérieusement de discuter le
sagement avec avec les britanniques qui
avaient voté en juin 2016 donc
évidemment on n'a pas voulu négocier en
fait donc donc à la fin effectivement ce
sont les pêcheurs français qui lisent de
trinquer mais ce sera la responsabilité
du gouvernement français pas les
britanniques peut pas les accuser là
dessus pour le reste moi ça me fait rire
de voir l'union européenne faire la
leçon ou ses porte paroles c'est à dire
les ministres français faire la leçon
sur le respect des traités du désaccord
puisque puisqu'on sait très bien en 2011
par exemple l'union européenne à violer
ses propres traités qu'elle ne viole en
permanence est donc allé violent qu'en
salle et quand ça l'arrangé et en
revanche elle ne rebelles demandent le
respect absolu des textes quand ça les
arrange aussi ça montre que cette
structure dont la vie doit absolument
disparaître le plus vite possible parce
qu'elle n'a pas de principes directeurs
il faut faire le fric site le plus vite
possible dans ce cas c'est le souhait
des patriotes vous le savez voilà moi
c'est ce que j'ai à dire là dessus et
est encore une fois que les britanniques
face de la realpolitik un qu'ils
défendent leur intérêt national dans les
négociations qui est un peu un moment à
biaiser
oui à faire un petit coup tordu ça ne
choque pas on n'a qu'à faire la même
chose on a peut-être un peu plus malins
et moi aussi à défendre nos intérêts
nationaux
plutôt que de faire confiance à les
textes et européen défendue par des
technocrates se gaver par des lobbys
financiers
frédéric viale le mot de la fin pour
vous les anglais en dehors de l'europe
quel est concrètement le risque pas si
grande selon vous vous relativisez oui
évidemment c'est à dire que là
maintenant la véritable échéance qui est
celle qui se posent à l'union européenne
est ouvert non britannique
ce n'est pas les 38 jours par doc a
annoncé johnson c'est le 3 novembre le 3
novembre il ya 20 il va y avoir des
élections aux états unis ce sera trump
ou pas trump city c'est rock
alors effectivement johnson va se sentir
des ailes pour faire une diplomatie on
va dire assez iconoclaste qui sera
encore keira encore plus loin on va dire
dans le symbole de la rupture mais sur
le chou que ce soit trump ou un autre on
aura de toute façon des relations avec
entre l'union européenne qui est néo
libérale et le gouvernement britannique
et néolibéral on aura des relations de
libre échange
le reste c'est un petit peu on va dire
de la rodomontade c'est un petit peu des
muscles qu'on montre comme ça dans des
négociations rien de plus merci en tout
cas tous les deux frédéric viale florian
philippot d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
débat sur le break site alors qu'on
attend donc lundi le huitième à la 8ème
séance de négociations